[Music]
hello everyone i'm shina takahashi and
i'll be your guide for today's nintendo
direct
hello i'm yoshiaki koizumi and i'll be
your guide as well
the nintendo switch system is now in its
fifth year
and many people around the world are
playing games on it
nintendo switch is being enjoyed by a
wide range of players spanning all ages
and all levels of gaming experience
thank you all very much
we've been able to offer a wide variety
of games on the system
not just from nintendo but also from our
many development and publishing partners
i hope that each of you watching this
nintendo direct will be able to find a
game that suits your personal tastes
today we have news on upcoming nintendo
switch games and we'll be focusing on a
selection of games releasing this year
we hope you enjoy it
okay to begin please take a look at this
video
hmm
get ready for the next battle
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wins
uh
and the director of the super smash
brothers ultimate game kazuya mishima
from the fighting game series tekken
will join the battle surprise
i'll go over the details at a later date
so please sit tight
for today though we've prepared a short
video to showcase kazia's moves in super
smash brothers ultimate please take a
look
[Music]
[Music]
kids
[Music]
[Music]
this feels like tekken
no it's super smash bros ultimate
i'll talk about the fighter more in a
future presentation
we still have to record it first
actually
the air date is shown below please stay
tuned
thank you mr sakurai
[Music]
new fighter kazuya will join the fight
in super smash brothers ultimate
please look forward to seeing how kazuya
who has experienced many harsh battles
across the tekken series will fight in
this game
alright let's continue with our first
batch of nintendo switch headlines
your choices matter in these emotional
supernatural tales
i will remember you
[Music]
[Music]
strong
is
[Music]
[Music]
life is strange true colors launches on
nintendo switch september 10th and life
is strange remastered collection comes
to nintendo switch later this year
there's something for everyone on the
nintendo switch system
you are star-lord leading a legendary
band of heroes for hire in this
thrilling action-adventure game jump on
a wild ride across the cosmos overwhelm
opponents with star-lords daring combat
style and encounter iconic and original
marvel characters you'll call the shots
for the unpredictable guardians as you
face cosmic threats to save the galaxy
you got this probably
marvel's guardians of the galaxy blasts
onto nintendo switch october 26th
worms everywhere
in this real-time arena-based shooter
you'll squish your invertebrate
opponents in 32-player cross-platform
combat play in daily challenges battle
modes and seasonal events to warm your
way up the ranks
plus the patchwork bear outfit exclusive
to the nintendo switch version will be
available for free for two weeks after
launch a new map spaceport showdown
launches with worm's rumble wriggling
onto nintendo switch june 23rd get a 25
discount when you pre-order the game
starting today on nintendo eshop
the fantastical realm of or canon awaits
as you explore this fully hand-painted
world you'll customize a team of
demigods and unleash devastating attacks
in captivating turn-based combat
astria ascending launches on nintendo's
witch september 30.
return to the funny charming and quirky
world of two point county
in the wholesome management sim two
point campus you'll build and run your
very own university the way you want it
lots of creative tools are at your
disposal to make the school yours and
take your educational empire to the next
level
enrollment for two point campus starts a
nintendo switch next year
[Music]
a beloved series rolls into its 20th
anniversary this year
[Music]
yahoo
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go bananas when super monkey ball banana
mania rolls onto nintendo switch october
5th
it's a blast from parties pass and
you're invited
ready for another round of mario party
mayhem of course you are it's a
superstar collection of mario party
boards and mini games
live it up on five classic boards from
the nintendo 64 era including peach's
birthday cake and space land
each board is packed with zany events
guaranteed to keep you on your toes and
when we say zany we mean it
jump
connect blocks
and give facelifts
in hilarious over-the-top mini-games
all of which support button controls
with 100 mini-games from the mario party
series catalog you'll have a blast in
this all-star fun fest
here's a little party favor all game
modes work with online play
even if you're partying solo you can
randomly match with other partygoers
worldwide
playing a board game online with friends
save your progress mid-game grab a snack
then resume the festivities
stickers are also available to
communicate with others
it's time to partay in mario party
superstars launching on the nintendo
switch system october 29th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
[Music]
what did you think
before we show this next trailer i'd
like to say one thing
currently we're working hard on the
latest game in the metroid prime series
metroid prime 4 which we previously
announced
but today we'd like to introduce another
new entry in the metroid franchise
please take a look
so
[Music]
so
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the trailer for the first new
2d metroid game in roughly 19 years
the brand new metroid dread game
as the name dread implies
this is a metroid game with a new feel
showcasing a variety of threats that
samus will encounter
it's scheduled to be released on october
8th so it won't be too long until launch
on that same day we'll also be releasing
amiibo figures for samus and the emmy
the robot seen in the video
let's move on to more nintendo switch
headlines
these familiar franchises are back on
nintendo switch
get ready to get down in the latest just
dance game
[Music]
the arcade smash hit and blast is
speeding onto nintendo switch
blast your way through nearly 30
over-the-top tracks
up to four players can race together so
pick your favorite vehicle and hit the
road
cruising blast launches as a console
exclusive on nintendo switch this fall
it's the ultimate dragon ball z
experience
relive the story of goku and other z
fighters through four sagas in this
action rpg
[Music]
saiyan
protect the earth from an invasion by
vegeta in napa
frieza take a stand against the evil
emperor
sell
battle the androids in a fight to the
death
majin buu an epic showdown with the most
fearsome foe
along with the main story you can
explore the vast world of dragon ball z
hey why not help out the locals
or collect ingredients for delicious
meals
you could always train to acquire new
skills too
there are lots of things to keep you
busy
the boss battle episodes a new power
awakens parts 1 and 2 is also included
dragon ball z kakarot plus a new power
awaken set punches its way onto nintendo
switch september 24th
grab a golf club and get ready to tee
off
the mario golf super rush game launches
soon
here's a quick glimpse into each of the
modes
standard golf
take your time to read the wind and
terrain on the greens
[Music]
get different types of shots aim for
under par
nice burger
speed golf
smack your ball then chase after it be
the first to get your ball in the hole
outpace your rivals with special dashes
and special shots
[Music]
battlegolf
duke it out over nine flag marked holes
in an obstacle filled arena
capture three flags to win
golf adventure
go from rookie to pro with your me
character
the golfing challenges that await may
surprise you
[Music]
and here's some news
free updates are planned for future
release including additional courses and
playable characters
the fairway's almost open
so set your tee time and get ready to
ace those shots in mario golf super rush
swinging onto the nintendo switch system
june 25th pre-orders are available now
on nintendo eshop
[Music]
ready for the ride of a lifetime
welcome to the vast and vibrant world of
monster hunter
as a rider in this rpg adventure you'll
explore diverse landscapes by riding
your monster a monster companion
gather materials such as honey and ore
then use them to craft items for your
journey
[Music]
but beware of the many monsters roaming
about
some are docile but others may suddenly
ambush
to fight you'll team up with your
monster and use weapons and skills to
overwhelm enemy monsters in turn-based
battles
win and you'll be rewarded with their
materials
which can be forged into new weapons and
armor
hey is that an egg you might be able to
hatch a new monster
incredibly powerful monsters can also
hatch from rare eggs
need more traveling buddies
join up with friends for co-op
multiplayer quests and battles
buckle up ryder it's going to be a real
monster of an adventure
monster hunter stories 2 wings of ruin
soars onto nintendo switch july 9th
you can play the free demo on june 25th
and carry over your save data to the
full game
[Music]
here's a new game from the head of a
certain company
[Music]
did you miss me hey what do you mean who
am i
it's a me wario
and it's a finally ready a brand new
game from my company
check it out you get to control me
time to do this
look at me go
what rats
check out these chunks they came back
and they have wonderful new talents
throw that stick thing
not the bad use the spinning what you
might call it
nailed it
same micro game different abilities
i almost forgot some big news
two people can play together at the same
time
so be nice or else
not nice all right you yes you the one
watching this better get ready for some
micro game mayhem
the warioware get it together game
launches exclusively on the nintendo
switch system september 10th pre-orders
begin today on nintendo eshop
[Music]
what you just saw was the trailer for
warioware
get it together
in the latest installment of this series
there are new micro games that let you
control wario and his friends
there is also a two player co-op mode
which greatly expands the gameplay
it's releasing in the near future so
stay tuned
next please take a look at this
as a high school student living in tokyo
your life is
fairly normal
[Music]
but that reality is upended
after you get pulled into a different
dimension
another tokyo exists a post-apocalyptic
world
where angels and demons reside
suddenly
you fuse with a mysterious figure
gaining the power to fight demons
what lies ahead in this alternate realm
the world is now transformed into a
sprawling demon-infested wasteland
though friendly demons do exist here
many are hostile
and will attempt to destroy you
harness your newfound powers to fight
demons using a command-based system
finding their weak point is key by
targeting it the number of consecutive
actions you can perform in a combo will
increase
though demons are formidable opponents
you may be able to recruit them via
negotiations
which begin when you open a conversation
with them
[Music]
[Applause]
if a negotiation is successful a demon
will become a powerful ally
in some cases by rejecting a demon's
request
they may feel motivated and join you as
an ally
demons that do join will fight alongside
you and grow stronger
by fusing demon allies another demon can
be created
[Music]
the newly fused demon's innate abilities
will vary granting you a powerful ally
customized to your needs and play style
challenge the many demons roaming this
post-apocalyptic world by harnessing the
power of your own
what destiny will you choose
shin megami tensei 5 will launch
exclusively on nintendo switch november
12th
pre-orders for the physical version
begin june 21st
[Applause]
that was the latest trailer for shin
megami tensei 5 from atlas
this is the newest game in the series
please look forward to future updates
let's see a few more nintendo switch
headlines
celebrate 10 years of danganronpa in
despair
testing testing mic check one two this
is a test of the school broadcast system
[Music]
three games in the deadly dankan rampa
series are coming to nintendo switch
i
am this cool monokuma the
self-proclaimed school headmaster has
trapped you and other high school
students in a game of literal life and
death unfortunately the only way out of
the school and this lethal game is to
betray the other students
and so it begins
a body has been discovered
when a student meets their demise a
class trial will take place to reveal
the culprit you're the culprit aren't
you me tonya i have no idea they've
probably moved the body there use the
evidence you've gathered to refute
contradictions and find the guilty party
sneak attack
are you okay
[Music]
plus the board game from dunkin rompa v3
killing harmony has been expanded into a
standalone game
duncan rampa s ultimate summer camp
an all-star cast of characters from the
duncan rumpa series will come together
to battle at a tropical resort
who's the strongest of them all in this
ultimate beach brawl
[Music]
the four-game collection duncan rampa
decadence launches as a physical
exclusive on nintendo switch later this
year
all four games will also be individually
available on nintendo eshop
[Music]
we hope you're not afraid of ghosts
[Music]
in this horror adventure game you'll
uncover the mysteries surrounding the
ethereal but deadly mount hikami
believed to be at the center of many
disappearances
ghosts frequent this mountain
your only defense is a camera that can
repel and cast them out
[Music]
face your fears as you explore a variety
of unsettling locations
this spine chilling story features
various protagonists letting you
experience the game from different
perspectives new costumes and photo
modes are included in this version can
you investigate mount hikami
and stay alive
fatal frame maiden of black water creeps
onto nintendo switch this year
these games and dlc are coming soon some
even today
your war is not over
raise hell in the first campaign
expansion for doom eternal the ancient
gods part one
deeper and more challenging combat aways
as you eliminate hell's newest threats
in demon infested ruins and rain swept
terrain
the fate of the cosmos is in your hands
get slaying when this campaign expansion
launches a nintendo switch later today
get ramped up for two iconic
skateboarding games fully remastered in
hd
skate to era defining jams as the
legendary tony hawk and a roster of new
and returning pros
take your sessions on the go with all
the original game modes
and compete locally or online to show
off your tricks against other skaters
drop in to tony hawk's pro skater one
and two launching on nintendo switch
june 25th
pre-orders are available now on nintendo
eshop
after 4 000 years sateky the witch queen
has risen from the dead and only one
group of heroes can stop her
the strange brigade
in this thrilling adventure you'll blast
through an army of mummified
monstrosities while solving puzzles in
booby-trapped dungeons go it alone or
team up with other daring adventurers in
local wireless co-op and online play
[Music]
expect the unexpected when strange
brigade launches a nintendo switch later
today
it's a new adventure of cosmic
proportions
mario and his friends will team up with
the rabbids once again to restore order
to the galaxy
our heroes must stop a mysterious new
evil from plunging the universe into
chaos
rabbit rosalina joins them wait is she
bored already
explore planets filled with quirky
residents and even quirkier secrets
and in this fresh take on the tactical
genre
our heroes can run freely around the
battlefield creating new strategic and
chaotic possibilities
so aim for victory with a little help
from your friends
wait
who's that
well one thing's certain this is gonna
be one heck of a galactic adventure
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
launches into space or onto nintendo
switch next year
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
thrilling stories memorable characters
and vibrant gameplay are in store as you
lead the commanding officers to victory
[Music]
play the first two advance wars
campaigns and advance wars one plus two
reboot camp marching onto nintendo
switch this holiday pre-orders begin
today on nintendo eshop
how is everything
all right this next segment will be our
last announcement of the day
please take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
producer of the legend of zelda series
what you've just seen is a trailer for
the first wave of dlc for the hyrule
warriors age of calamity expansion pass
from koe tecmo games
it will follow link and his allies
through more battles that took place 100
years prior to the events of the legend
of zelda breath of the wild i hope
you'll look forward to it
i have a few more things to share with
you all today
[Music]
we'll begin with the legend of zelda
skyward sword hd game which launches
next month
[Music]
you'll immerse yourself in the role of
link by using two joy-con controllers
for intuitive motion controls
or by playing in handheld mode wielding
the sword via flicking the stick and
button only controls
this game depicts the oldest era in the
legend of zelda series the story of how
it all began
what is the origin of the master sword
why did a woman named zelda become the
legend for future generations
these will all be unraveled in this game
we hope you're looking forward to the
legend of zelda skyward sword hd
[Music]
next up
here's a little something you might like
this is a gamin watch system that lets
you play three games in the legend of
zelda series this year the original
legend of zelda game reaches its 35th
anniversary
while we don't have any campaigns or
other nintendo switch games planned
we've been working on this game watch
system as a special item to help mark
the occasion and reflect fondly on the
earliest days of the legend of zelda
[Music]
it will come with the first game in the
series the legend of zelda
zelda 2 the adventure of link
and the game boy version of the legend
of zelda link's awakening game
as well as a special version of the game
watch title vermin starring link as the
playable character
so that's four games on one system from
longer legend of zelda games to the pick
up and play game vermin
in addition regarding the watch
functionality for the game watch system
we've added a playable clock based on
the legend of zelda
and an interactive timer themed after
zelda 2 the adventure of link
you can play with both of them by taking
control of link
we hope you'll enjoy playing this game
and watch system whenever and wherever
you'd like
all right here's the last thing we have
to show you
this is the sequel to the legend of
zelda breath of the wild
two years have passed since we first
announced this game and we've been
unable to share anything with you in
that time
however development has been steadily
progressing for today we've prepared
some new footage to show a bit more of
the game please take a look
[Music]
[Music]
so
ah
[Music]
so what did you think this time around
the setting for the adventure has been
expanded to include the skies above
hyrule
we'd like to ask you to wait a bit
longer
we're aiming for a 2022 release so i
hope you'll look forward to it
[Music]
how was that
that's all for this nintendo
direct we are diligently continuing
development on a number of other games
we didn't show today i hope you'll
continue looking forward to what's in
store on nintendo switch
thank you for watching
[Music]
you